y no respire respiren cada dos años las
mujeres mayores de 50 años en francia
pueden participar en la detección del
cáncer de mama de forma gratuita rossi
link ha estado participando desde 2010
mi ginecólogo me dijo que hiciera una
mamografía así que lo hice y fue
entonces cuando me diagnosticaron este
fibroma es bueno saber hacia dónde vamos
qué podemos hacer y si no es demasiado
tarde el hospital gustave roussy es el
principal centro europeo de lucha contra
el cáncer allí descubrieron que la
mayoría de mujeres no se atrevían a ir a
consulta durante el confinamiento está
bien todo está bien como parte del
examen organizado hay un segundo
radiólogo que se asegurará de que no
falte nada este retraso a veces empeora
los diagnósticos la paciente esperó
medio año a causa del hobbit como se ha
advertido mi facebook
ella había comenzado a palpar una
hinchazón en un seno antes del periodo
encierro y no volvió sino hasta finales
de agosto
ahora tenemos una masa blanca si
comparamos con el lado en el que hay
tumor maligno de mama
el hecho de haber esperado seis meses
hizo que hoy sea de esta talla por eso
hoy el tratamiento es importante la
quimioterapia cirugía más radioterapia
pero es importante no acostumbrarse a
sentir algo que persiste que no se mueve
con el ciclo y que podría ser una lesión
sospechosa de la mama
cada año cerca de 12.000 mujeres en el
mundo mueren por cáncer de mama